[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 nous sommes le lundi 18
mai voici les titres de ce journal les
conseillers désignés dès le premier tour
des municipales sont entrés en fonction
aujourd'hui dans le département 2 115
communes sont concernées les élus vont
se réunir entre le 23 et 28 mai pour
choisir leurs maires et adjoints exemple
dans cette édition à saint quentin en
yvelines l'agglomération qui a vécu il
ya une semaine le déconfinement comme
partout en france
respect des gestes barrières
distanciation sociale quels sont les
changements sur le territoire éléments
de réponse et puis le déconfinement a
permis à tout un ensemble de professions
de reprendre leurs activités c'est le
cas notamment des ostéopathes reportage
dans un cabinet à versailles qui a dû
revoir son organisation pour ouvrir un
second tour en juin à l'automne ou en
2021 le conseil scientifique doit rendre
entre ce lundi soir et demain son avis
au gouvernement concernant les élections
municipales le premier ministre edouard
philippe devrait s'appuyer sur les
conclusions de ce rapport pour décider
de la date du scrutin qui devrait être
soumis au vote des parlementaires
hier dans le journal du dimanche 36
maires ont appelé dans une tribune à la
tenue du second tour en juin parmi eux
arnaud péricard élu à saint germain en
laye dans les yvelines les électeurs
n'ont pas réussi à départager les
candidats de 44 communes à l'issue du
premier tour
en revanche pour les autres feu vert
pour l'installation des maires et
adjoints élus dès le 15 mars dernier les
conseils municipaux entre en fonction
aujourd'hui et doivent être installés
entre le 23 et le 28 mai prochain à
saint quentin en yvelines cinq communes
sont concernées ont fait le point avec
aurélie ans le samedi 23 mai à 10h30 la
ville de montigny le bretonneux sera la
première commune de saint quentin en
yvelines installé son conseil municipal
si le préfet des yvelines l'autorisent
il pourrait se dérouler à la grange de
la ferme du manet en présence du public
nous sommes en train d'organiser
effectivement les choses pour que les
chaque personne puisse avoir ses quatre
mètres carrés elle que
quelle qu'elles sont demandées par par
l'état nous avons la capacité
étant donnée la superficie de la salle
de la grande d'accueillir aussi un petit
peu public donc nous en avons fait la
demande au préfet nous attendons son
retour
et si le préfet elle accepte tant mieux
nous pourrons accueillir un petit peu de
public
sinon nous l'organiserons à huis clos et
dans ce cas là nous nous sommes en train
de regarder pour assurer une
retransmission de la du conseil pour que
le leader bien sûr son caractère public
à maurepas le nouveau conseil municipal
sera mise en place également le samedi
23 mai à 15 heures pour respecter les
règles de distanciation il se déroulera
au gymnase de la malle me donne
l'installation du conseil qui sera
également déplacé à coignières un
conseil à huis clos le lundi 25 mai à
19h45 à la maison de voisinage sa durée
sera volontairement plus courte en
raison des règles sanitaires à la nation
l'élection du maire tout d'abord avec là
ça va être le pr je dirais la première
délibération à l'élection du maire
ensuite il ya la détermination du nombre
d'adjoints
donc on va rester sur ce que l'on avait
fait précédemment c'est à dire huit
adjoints et le nombre aussi de
conseiller délégué donc nous en aurons
trois ans suite à l'élection des
adjoints et puis ensuite il ya la
délégation des pouvoirs aubert aussi que
l'on va pas très lors de ce conseil et
puis enfin la débilité des élus à
elancourt l'installation du nouveau
conseil municipal se déroulera le
mercredi 27 mai l'heure et le lieu sont
encore à définir
enfin magny les hameaux le conseil se
déroulera à huis clos le jeudi 28 mai à
19 heures salle de festivités au trait
d'union
au total cinq communes saint quentinois
sont concernés par ces installations de
conseils municipaux dans les yvelines 2
115 communes ont désigné leur mère au
premier tour en mars dernier les
yvelines où plus de 20 recours ont été
déposés suite aux résultats des
municipales dans les communes où les
maires ont été élus dès le premier tour
c'est le cas notamment à maurepas aux
chaînés rocancourt ou encore à chevreuse
ou l'élection s'est jouée à une seule
voie et des actions en justice qui ne
sont pas suspensives tant que la
procédure ne va pas au bout
elle est rendu des jugements
ne sont pas attendus avant plusieurs
mois depuis une semaine les élèves
reprennent peu à peu le chemin de
l'école à elancourt qui a rouvert ses
établissements depuis jeudi dernier deux
écoles ont été fermées temporairement
par mesure de précaution en raison de
suspicions au co vie de 19
il s'agit de l'école maternelle willy
brandt ou un enfant à présenter des
signes de fièvre modérée à l'élémentaire
de lavilledieu c'est un adulte qui a
ressenti le même symptôme ce week end
ces deux personnes reçues en
consultation ne présente aucun signe
alarmant
des tests doivent être pratiqués en
début de semaine pour l'ensemble des
membres des familles par souci de
cohérence et de prudence la ville
d'elancourt n'assurera pas de service
minimum d'accueil pour ces deux groupes
scolaires
une semaine après le début du
déconfinement les hospitalisations liées
aux coronavirus sont repartis en légère
hausse dans les yvelines c'est une
première depuis à 15 jours hier à 628
patients étaient hospitalisés sur le
territoire de plus en 24 heures 48 placé
en réanimation
le département ou 464 décès sont
survenus dans les hôpitaux
enfin c'est une première également
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
aucune guérison supplémentaire n'a été
enregistrés entre samedi et dimanche
1759 personnes sont revenus à domicile
suite à une amélioration de leur état de
santé
le déconfinement se veut progressif avec
c'est une nécessité pour éviter une
deuxième vague grave le respect strict
des gestes barrières et des mesures de
distanciation social quels sont les
changements dans l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines
les précisions doré lyons c'est un
accessoire désormais indispensable si
vous empruntez les transports en commun
à saint quentin en yvelines
le masque est obligatoire avant de
monter dans un bus ou dans un train sous
peine d'amendés aux heures de pointe
c'est à dire entre 6h30 et 9 heures 30
et de 16 heures à 19 heures il faut par
ailleurs être muni d'une attestation de
votre employeur enfin si vous souhaitez
privilégier une mobilité plus douce la
vélostation situé à la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines a rouvert ses portes
sur rendez vous il est possible de louer
un vélo ou encore de le faire réparer
les boutiques de l'espace saint quentin
rouvrent peu à peu depuis quelques jours
en mettant en place des mesures
sanitaires spécifiques les bars cafés et
restaurants restent quant à eux fermés à
l'exception de ceux qui proposent de la
vente à emporter
de leur côté les agriculteurs saint
quentinois maintiennent les dispositifs
mis en place pendant la crise
enfin un groupe facebook permet aux
commerçants et producteurs de mettre en
avant leurs actions
les sept déchetteries de saint quentin
en yvelines sont ouvertes partiellement
certains services comme la mise à
disposition de sacs déchets verts ou la
collecte des bandes textiles sont encore
suspendus
la collecte des encombrants a repris l
le 11 mai dernier
notez que leur accès se fait uniquement
sur rendez vous
[Musique]
le déconfinement a permis la reprise de
balades en forêt en revanche les parcs
et les jardins de saint quentin en
yvelines reste fermé la pratique des
activités sportives est également de
nouveau autorisée avec tout de même
plusieurs critères en extérieur et en
respectant certaines distances 10 mètres
minimum pour les activités de vélo et du
jogging 4 mètres carrés pour le yoga ou
encore le fitness les golf de saint
quentin en yvelines ont également
rouvert avec des mesures d'hygiène et de
sécurité
en revanche pour se divertir
culturellement il faudra faire preuve
encore de patience cinéma celle de
spectacles musées reste fermé pour les
médiathèques tout de même vous pouvez
accéder gratuitement aux ressources en
ligne jusqu'au 30 juin
avec la limitation des déplacements et
probablement l'interdiction de sortir du
territoire de l'union européenne ce sont
plus de cinquante cinq mille jeunes
yvelinois des quartiers prioritaires qui
ne pourront pas partir en vacances pour
les accompagner le département des
yvelines lance quartiers d'été c'est une
opération de 2,6 millions d'euros pour
l'organisation d'activités culturelles
sportives ou encore éducative
l'enveloppent permettra de soutenir les
projets des communes en ce sens où
l'organisation encore de vacances à
prenantes au sein du campus
départemental des mureaux à la verrière
une distribution de masques de
protection était organisée vendredi
dernier à destination de trois
associations caritatives de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ces structures
sont principalement mobilisés pour aider
les personnes fragiles dans les
quartiers prioritaires le reportage de
michael et demi d'euros une distribution
de masques pour les associations
caritatives de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
en première ligne pendant tout le
confinement
trois associations située à la verrière
et l'encours et rap ont reçu le matériel
ce vendredi 15 mai l'initiative a été
menée conjointement par le département
est une entreprise spécialisée dans la
confection de vêtements personnalisés
que pour protéger les autres il fallait
qu'ils puissent être protégées donc cela
permet de pouvoir courir leur action et
ça c'est très important pour moi et pour
mon équipe aussi qui est très heureuse
de participer à ce don peut pas les
laisser tomber
il faut qu'on agisse chacun à notre
niveau nous en tant qu'élu les
associations or avec toutes leurs
activités caritatives
et puis les entrepreneurs aussi doivent
mouiller le maillot et c'est je trouve
une belle action de mêlée ces trois
acteurs de terrain pour aider les
familles les plus en difficulté au total
entreprise a fait don de 200 masques
jetables et sans masque lavables une
bonne nouvelle pour cette structure
implantée dans le bois de l'étang qui
distribuent des colis alimentaires et
une vingtaine de familles chaque mois
les mains seront distribués à des amis
bénévoles et pourquoi pas aussi les
distribuer aux familles qui en ont
besoin aussi parce que c'est aussi le
but parce que le masque à masquer ça
coûte très cher donc si de notre côté on
peut les distribuer à différentes
familles c'est aussi c'est aussi utile
et le soc inutilité d'autres masques de
ce type pourraient être distribués dans
les prochaines semaines à d'autres
structures du territoire des yvelines
dans l'actualité également les
conséquences économiques de la crise du
coronavirus plusieurs enseignes ont été
placées en redressement judiciaire
dernier en date
alinéa spécialisée dans l'ameublement et
la décoration implanté dans les yvelines
notamment dans la zone commerciale de
plaisir les clayes sous bois et deux
scénarios pour garantir la survie le
dépôt d'un plan de continuation par les
actionnaires ou encore l'appel à
d'éventuels repreneurs
situation similaire également pour
plusieurs enseignes de vêtements et
chaussures naf naf présente à l'espace
saint quentin andrea westfield parly 2
ou encore la halle avec un magasin à
plaisir qui a jusqu'au 25 mai pour
trouver un repreneur
après avoir été largement à l'arrêt
pendant deux mois d'activité économique
est cependant à la reprise dans les
yvelines comment se déroulent les
événements depuis le 11 mai quelles
perspectives
éléments de réponse dans cet entretien
mené par nicolas d'andrus cette reprise
d'activité avec le déconfinement du 11
mai un bol d'air pour une partie du
tissu économique yvelinois fortement
impacté par les huit semaines de
confinement pour en parler
gérard mâchouiller bonjour bonjour
président de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des yvelines alors avant de
parler de la relance quel bilan
provisoire faites-vous des conséquences
du coc vie de 10,9 sur la situation
économique dans le département
dans notre département l'activité a été
moins touchée que pour le reste de
l'ile-de-france puisqu'on à une baisse
d'activité d'à peu près 60% alors que
pour le reste de l'ile-de-france a été
65%
c'est d'ailleurs le même constat pour le
chômage partiel puisque les demandes de
chômage partiel concerne 45 % des
entreprises dans les yvelines
alors que pour l'île de france cela
concerne 60 2 % des entreprises
donc nous sommes plutôt favorisé dans
les yvelines j'irai dans cette phase
difficile et en fait les demandes de
chômage partiel
c'est à peu près cent seize mille
demandes d'indemnisation pour donc les
entreprises des yvelines ce qui
représente à peu près 85 millions
d'euros
donc qui ont été distribués alors bon
c'est dire et les entreprises des
yvelines c'est surtout les services et
tout ce qui est commerce hôtellerie
restauration bien sûr qui a fait ces
demandes de chômage partiel et j'espère
que ça va donner justement pour certains
ça va ça les a bien aidés de plus au
niveau du fonds de solidarité qui a eu à
peu près 30 6 millions d'euros donc qui
ont été demandés pour le fonds de
solidarité ça représente à peu près 1000
352 euros par part entreprises avec des
versements d'après ce que disent les
entreprises des versements assez rapide
il y a normalement à deuxième volet donc
de ce fonds de solidarité
il ya très peu de monde dans ce deuxième
volet puisque il ya actuellement que
5000 demandes sont dans ce deuxième
volet c'est bien sûr également les mêmes
entreprises c'est-à-dire commerce
hôtellerie événementiel service
confessions mans et je crois que donc
c'est aussi ce qui concerne le tourisme
et les quais et bienvenue actuellement
c'est les annonces du premier ministre
hier concernant justement les aides
prévues pour le tourisme le tourisme en
a bien besoin parce que je pense que les
activités touristiques ne vont pas
reprendre tout de suite et il est
important justement que on est
particulièrement le tourisme la
restauration l'hôtellerie
mancienne ce sont des activités
importantes au niveau des prêts garantis
par l'état
il y à peu près 5588 près que tu ai
demandé dans les yvelines qui représente
à peu près 900 millions d'euros dont qui
ont été demandés avec toujours des
remontées de frilosité des banques qui
peuvent effectivement demandé des
prévisionnels qui sont impossibles à
donner pour les entreprises est bon la
bonne nouvelle c'est effectivement que
tout refus en dessous de 50 mille euros
doit être notifiée par écrit par la
banque
hélas beaucoup d'entreprises devraient
faire appel au médiateur du crédit
lorsqu'elles n'ont pas lorsqu'elles ont
des refus et bien sûr la cci est à leur
service pour pour les aider alors le
dernier point c'est par rapport au
tribunal de commerce
bizarrement il ya très peu de donc de
liquidation tribunal de commerce la
moitié des députations habituel et puis
il ya bien sûr aussi très peu de
d'immatriculation je pense que le
tribunal de commerce attend à une
influence d'arrivée justement de
dossiers à partir de septembre octobre
et je crois que il a raison je crois
qu'il y aura beaucoup de dossiers qui
vont arriver à partir de cette date
malheureusement malgré le déconfinement
malgré le déconfinement parce que
beaucoup d'activités n'ont pas repris
vraiment complètement et je pense qui
malgré les aides malgré de déconfinement
bon bon d'après d'après le président du
tipnis du tribunal de commerce
il y risque d'y avoir beaucoup de
difficultés parce que il sait aussi
qu'il ya des entreprises qui étaient pas
dans des situations très facile
justement avant la crise comment s'est
passé le déconfinement dans les
entreprises yvelinoise quel regard vous
portez justement sur le dé confinement
et la manière dont les entreprises se
sont organisés
je crois que ça se passe plutôt bien on
a moins de problèmes de transport dans
les yvelines bien sûr puisque et je
pense que ça aussi ça milite pour une
déconcentration des activités en ile de
france vers la grande couronne moi c'est
je pense que justement la crise montre
qu' il faudrait déconcentré un petit peu
les centres où tout le monde s'agglutine
et avoir une déconcentration vers la
grande couronne
il ya bien sûr la problématique des
masques des gels des protections
l'organisation du travail qui est
constitué un coup supplémentaire pour
des entreprises en particulier pour le
btp et il ya des difficultés pour
certains métiers justement btp bien être
beauté pour pouvoir mettre en place les
mesures barrières
il y en a bien sûr nous les les chambres
consulaires donc chambre de métiers
chambre de commerce et d'industrie on a
participé la distribution de masques qui
ont été attribuées par le conseil
régional d'ile-de-france masque donc
attribuer gratuitement et qu'on a
distribués depuis deux semaines donc les
distributions se font au commerce aux
tpe pme aux artisans
le medef est hélas et là ces pme ont
également participé à ces distribution
de masques donc ça permet à certaines
entreprises peut-être pas tout d'avoir
en tout cas des masques pour une
quinzaine de jours et pouvoir
fonctionner sur quinze jours après le
commerce au niveau du commerce qui est
l'inquiétude justement parce que il
risque d'y avoir une moindre
fréquentation parce que bien sûr les
clients hésitent pour venir pour aller
dans les commerces encore et puis il ya
le cas des centres commerciaux des
centres commerciaux donc jean mode et
maison qu'ils sont et one man one nation
qui ont ouvert qui ont permis donc
qu'ils sont ouverts mais il ya malgré
tout des dj de et parly 2 qui font plus
que quarante mille mètres carrés comme
pas pu ouvrir ça peut créer des
difficultés pour les commerçants
justement de ces centres commerciaux et
on espère justement qu'ils auront les
autorisations assez rapide justement
pour pouvoir ouvrir parce que pour ces
commerçants c'est quand même très
important merci gérard bacheliers je
vous en prie président de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie des yvelines
une nouvelle directrice pour les
établissements renault d'île de france
il s'agit d' hélène favier dont la
nomination est effective depuis le 1er
avril dernier et qui devient à ce titre
également et directrice du technocentre
à guyancourt est diplômé de l'essec
entré chez renault en 1993 elle était
depuis février 2016 directrice des
ressources humaines et de la
communication pour une filiale de la
marque au losange
outre le technocentre hélène favier
dirigera également entre autres le
centre technique de villiers saint
frédéric dans les yvelines
si les soins médicaux n'ont pas cessé
pendant le confinement les activités
paramédicales ont repris depuis la
semaine dernière seulement certains
cabinets ont ouvert c'est le cas pour
les ostéopathes espacement des
rendez-vous nettoyage régulier du
matériel organisation qui a dû être
aussi repensé comme vous allez le voir
avec ce sujet de mélanie poquet à
versailles
paul biya retraite régulièrement des
tensions mais avec le confinement le
manque de sport et le stress les ont
renforcés pour la réouverture de son
cabinet cet ostéopathe versailles et a
dû revoir son organisation au niveau du
cabinet j'ai rallongé mais créneau donc
je prends le patient maintenant 1h15 au
lieu des 45 minutes une heure
habituel ce qui me permet de pouvoir
aérer le cabinet au moins pendant 15
minutes de pouvoir également désinfecter
les poignées désinfecter la table
désinfectez tout le mobilier ou le
patient va venir s'installer à
l'obligation de porter un masque il ya
du gel
à l'arrivée et dans le calme dans la
salle d'attenté
on est tout seul dans la salle l'attend
la bad est tombé non à élever voilà on
va pouvoir on va faire une différence
deux mois qu'il n'avait pas fait ses
gestes comme de nombreux praticiens paul
biard a dû fermer son cabinet du jour au
lendemain à l'annonce du confinement un
temps long pour certains patients ça
commence alors on va du dos donc je me
suis dit voilà il fallait que ça
reprenne parce que du coup je voulais
refaire une séance avec mon ostéopathe
est sur que derrière j'ai pas de souci
et dès que j'ai eus su qui reprenait les
rendez vous j'ai pris un spray contact
avec lui
cet ostéopathe a pu bénéficier d'être de
l'état un moyen pour lui de couvrir les
charges du cabinet et d'éliminer là
aussi quelques tensions
avant de vous laisser les étés des
milliers des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine a participé à cette
opération en compagnie notamment de la
star du paris saint-germain thiago silva
l'opération cinq mille collégiens à
versailles ne pourra pas se tenir cette
année en tout cas pas en présentiel
puisqu'aujourd'hui le château de
versailles a accueilli virtuellement ces
jeunes yvelinois et alto séquanais au
programme quiz animations photos et
vidéos postés durant toute la journée
sur le compte instagram du château un
livre numérique et est également
accessible sur les ent des collèges des
deux départements
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi très belle soirée à
tous sur tv 78
[Musique]